keep your eye on the Monitor and be
careful with the lights the Five Nights
of Freddy's animatronics are looking
creepier than ever here's the who's who
of Freddy Fazbear and friends have you
met them
yet met
who though one of the original
animatronics for the pizza restaurant
after only 4 years the classic Brown
Bear Freddy was replaced by an
animatronic called toy Freddy rather
than fix the original animatronics which
had fallen into a state of disrepair in
the first years of the restaurant's
existence because you know horror a
newer version was developed and by newer
we mean more terrifying Freddy Fazbear
is thought to be a later iteration of
fredbear an animatronic for fredbear's
Family Diner that's the restaurant that
preceded Freddy Fazbear's Pizza this
version of the animatronic is introduced
in the fourth game of the franchise
during which he appears as Nightmare
fredbear and though they share an
appearance it has not been confirm that
Freddy and fredbear are one and the same
despite fan theories fredbear was a
spring log animatronic meaning someone
could jump inside of the animatronic and
wear it like a costume the animatronic
had two separate modes to allow this and
to ensure that whoever was using it as a
costume would not be injured by the
mechanics of the animatronic portion the
same however could not be said for
people outside of the costume you see
there is controversy surrounding
fredbear while the Family diner was in
operation a child was forced by bullies
to put his head in fredbear's mouth
leading to the death of the child an
Infamous events that became known as the
bite of 83 the this also resulted in the
closing of fredbear's Family Diner and
the rebranding into Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza shortly after like Freddy Bonnie
the rabbit is one of the OG animatronics
of the restaurant chain though Bonnie
was replaced with a toy version at one
point the rabbit animatronic is
typically depicted as a bluish purple in
the games with a red bow tie it was this
version of Bonnie that debuted when the
pizzeria opened its doors though after
only 4 years the animatronic was retired
in favor of the toy version Bonnie's
first iteration was introduced when
fredbear's Family Diner reopened
referred to as spring bnny this first
animatronic was yellowish in color and
sported a purple bow tie spring Bonnie
has a spring lock mechanism that allows
someone to hide inside the animatronic
which was used for nefarious purposes by
Seri antagonist William Afton Bonnie is
a guitarist of the band and is
considered the most active of the bunch
regularly seeking out anyone in the
pizzeria to kill imagine character's
fright when the first animatronic to
show that it can move turns out to be
the cut innocent looking rabbit okay
maybe the phrase innocent looking is Up
For Debate but you get the point it is
important to note that despite commonly
being the aggressor of the animatronics
Bonnie is also the first to admit defeat
while he will go after people within the
pizzeria if deterred he will step back
and move on at least for the time being
that is there have been customer
complaints about chica's accurate smell
sounds like chica has been rumaging
around the kitchen again like fellow
animatronic fiends Freddy and Bonnie
Chica has gone through several
iterations over the course of the
franchise chica carries around another
character Mr Cupcake who will get to in
a bit chica's appearance differs a bit
from the other animatronics sporting a
bib with the phrase let's eat rather
than a bow tie instead of an instrument
or microphone chica holds a plate with a
cupcake like the others she was replaced
with a toy model only a few years into
the opening of the pizzeria as a backup
singer of the band chica doesn't always
have a rise on the price as a cupcake
might suggest CH could sense a go for
food over a human which is a phrase that
could only exist when talking about FNAF
chica also has a bit more patience than
her other mascots often standing in
place and waiting by a door so long as
she isn't distracted Foxy the pirate fox
is an animatronic with a bit of a
different story than the others while
Freddy Bonnie and Chica are all in a
band together on a stage foxy has a
swashbuckling stage of his own foxy goes
all in on the captain Sparrow cosplay
with an eye patch and a hug for a hand
because what pirate would be complete
without those however his initial
condition is a bit more concerning as
even before he is replaced with a toy
version and takes on his weathered
Incarnation he looks a little worse
forwar his fur is shredded there are
holes in the metal covering his body and
his jaw appears broken due to the way it
hangs like his fellow animatronic
monstrosities Foxy's whole vibe doesn't
exactly scream kid-friendly when he was
replaced as part of the toy versions his
new animatronic counterpart was given
the name mangle which yeah would say
that one's on the nose given its
dismantled appearance this was because
it was the decided that the original
Foxy design was a bit too scary for the
establishment and mangle was an attempt
to Rebrand the character into a more
child-friendly animatronic because you
know mangle is such a G-rated name and
all chica will wait you out Freddy will
taunt you and Bonnie will show no mercy
but he will run at you faster than
any of the other animatronics can he
tends to run down the hall in the first
game appearing out of thin air because
what better way for players to break in
those new brown pants often held by
chica Mr Cupcake AKA call isn't the
cupcake of every birthday child's dreams
despite his innocent sounding name with
pink frosting large eyes and a single
candle on top the delicious treat can
have a mind of its own on occasion
because the only thing scarier than
being attacked by the entertainment is
finding yourself at the mercy of devious
animatronic dessert Mr Cupcakes role in
the games changes often from hanging in
the security office to being a movable
object players can throw in Five Nights
at Freddy's Help Wanted there has been
much debate in the franchise over the
last several years about who the game so
called vengeful Spirits is and which
animatronic it resides in a fan Theory
as proposed by the YouTube channel Cura
Labs buzzed setus actually missed a
cupcake the theory combines knowledge
that the working title of the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie was bad cupcake
as seen in a film slate posted by Jason
Blum on Twitter and the cupcakes
appearances across fnaf's many entries
as far as a choice to use Mr Cupcake for
the working title of the movie rather
than one of the other animatronics the
individuals in the video argue that it
is UN likee FNAF Creator Scott coron to
select a title that doesn't have a
backhanded meaning causing them to think
more about a character that players may
forget about Mr Cupcake is also the only
animatronic that's already in the office
during the game more your goal is to
prevent the other animatronics from
entering the office Mr Cupcake is
already there this could be an indicator
that the worst bad guy was hiding in
plain sight all
along the heck spring trap is an
animatronic that appears in Five Nights
at Freddy's 3 he is s to an early
version of Bonnie or another version of
spring Bonny spring trap's exterior is
littered with holes and it is even
missing the metal covering on most of
its legs and feet which simulates a sort
of skeletal appearance spring trap also
doesn't have the bow tie seen in other
rabbit animatronics in the series so
he's keeping things business casual even
if he's in the business of scaring the
beas out of players unlike some of the
other animatronics which have MS that
move springtrap's mouth is locked into a
wide smile during gameplay showing off
the animatronics teeth in other words
springtrap is a definition of nightmare
fuel springtrap's name comes from
Surprise the spring lock mechanism
inside it like the other animatronics
with the same mechanism the mechanical
components inside are modified to allow
for someone to be inside the animatronic
however the spring locks and springtrap
malfunctioned hence the trap part of his
name despite being the embodiment of
every bad dream ever springtrap does
have a weakness he is attracted to noise
this can work both for and against the
player depending on the situation
if the player makes noise near Spring
trap in the third game spring trap will
follow it however if spring trap is
distracted by sounds coming from
elsewhere the player just might have a
Fighting Chance when it comes to
surviving an encounter with him
springtrap is the main animatronic and
antagonist of the third game with the
other animatronics appearing as Phantom
likee entities springtrap's inclusion in
the movie could hint at where future
flicks could go storylines that could be
centered in future movies and other
variations of animatronics that could
appear down the line